>>
MALE: So, first off, could you introduce your
company, give a brief overview of your application
and your motivations for creating it.
>> MALE: Well, we’re not a company actually,
we are just a project. I started with a friend
of mine about a year ago, part time. So we
are still seeing it moving it forward. And
we’ve created Storyteller, because today,
your life on the internet is fragmented across
many different place; pictures from Picasa,
video on YouTube, Google readers. That makes
it difficult for your friends to follow you.
It makes it difficult for you to search and
navigate that information. And more important,
it’s sort of, doesn’t help your online
identity. Your online identity is fragmented
across many different services. So when you
search for your name on Google, there’s
many different place that are showing up and
nothing that really shows who you really are.
So Storytellers solved that problem by bringing
all your data together in one place, which
is highly personal typically under the — your
own domain name so you can easily share it
with your friends. And we get our name Storyteller
because we enable people to mesh up, elements
these data together in sort of a story that
serves as a photo album that you can easily
share with your friends or keep as a memory.
So as an example, you’re going to a hike
or holiday, you tweet, post a pictures or
share a video, or you bring that together
in a nicely packaged, nice visual that we
call a story.
>> MALE: So, can you tell us a little bit
about how you came about, you know, choosing
to use these different GD and APIs access
a person’s information? Can you tell us
of how you came to this decision?
>> MALE: Well, the point of storyteller is
to bring the users data together. So Google
is the market leader on a lot of these data
source, like, YouTube or Picasa pictures,
for example. So it was just natural to get
the data. And YouTube and Google is very open
on its data source, fantastic APIs that you
could leverage. So it was natural first step
for us to first target the YouTube data APIs,
but, of course, we’re adding also, also
services which are not Google properties because
we really want to be able to cover the whole
range of data source on the internet.
>> MALE: Okay. So, as developers we really
value being able to share war stories or lessons
from technical challenges. Can you tell us
about one particular difficult period of development
that you faced and how you approached this
technical challenge?
>> MALE: I think I would just share with you
my biggest mistake on this project because
it’s a very good lesson learned. Initially,
we’ve developed this only for our own personal
page. So we didn’t think about this as a
product, so we didn’t think at all about
scalability, and we didn’t think at all
about internationalization. So I think for
a developer, if you believe in your product,
and if you believe what you’re building
is great, you should already think about being
huge, being large. I don’t mean you don’t
need to build a scale booth system first hand
but you need to think about it. Because, for
example, retrofitting a localization framework
in your application, it’s just a nightmare.
Today, I have to almost rewrite my whole code
base to be able to target different languages.
If I just have taken a few hours to think
through what framework I was going to use
for localization and translation, and to implement
that framework upfront, not to do all the
different languages, just to put the framework
in place, I think today would be okay but
right now we’re totally stuck. The same
thing with scalability, we have to rewrite
a huge part of our data access because we
didn’t think about simple things that would
have today save us a lot of time. So, if you
build something and you believe in it, it
is going to be big, think upfront of how you’re
going to make it scale, make it international,
just think that upfront, it’s going to save
you a lot of time.
>> MALE: So what were the benefits to your
app of using the Google Data APIs?
>> MALE: Well, one thing I find fantastic
in Google Data API is that they are built
on a uniform foundation called the GData protocol.
So it makes it very easy to port codes. So
if you build codes access to YouTube API,
for example, you can very easily then switch
to Picasa, for example, or the blogger APIs.
It's all built across this GData layer, it's
all [INDISTINCT] and you have a lot of different
ways to get the data, it would be Atom or
JSON. I think, honestly, it’s been one of
the simplest API to use amongst different
services we've targeted.
>> MALE: So this next question is a follow
up to that. Can you talk about how using Google
Data APIs has reduced the amount of work for
you? And could you please elaborate on how
this has happened?
>> MALE: Well, so as I mentioned earlier,
if you write codes to access YouTube and if
you spent time to learn the YouTube API, all
the knowledge you can translate to any of
the other Google API, because they are all
using the same foundation. So same thing with
your code, you can have a common code base
then you will specify for specific data source.
So that’s where, I think, you don’t have
to develop for each separate, it’s not like,
you have to spend time on YouTube then spend
time on Picasa. You just spend time on preparing
a foundation to access Google Data APIs, and
then you sort of get the rest for free. So
if tomorrow, Google will have a new API for
a new services, like Google reader, I think
it’s going to be, you know, very easy for
us to get it through. More important, another
important aspect is that Google support a
lot of different standards in terms of how
the data is expressed. All our code-base is
PHP, for example, so JSON was a very natural
fit or a lot of JSON links in PHP that works
quite well. And I think, Google is going to
introduce even more supports and more of this
kind of data description, so, you know, it's
all good for us.
>> MALE: So my last question is, what are
like, three things you’d like to see added
to Google Data APIs?
>> MALE: In our case, we want data to be as
fast as possible brought into our user’s
environment so we can display it but also
we can push it, for example, to social networks
they use. We have a lot of users, so we cannot
ask YouTube every minute, you know, what,
is there something new. So we want Google
to move forward in helping this real-time
Web to happen. For example, there is a simple
protocol called SUP, Simple Update Protocol
which simplifies a lot of this mechanism so
we don’t have to go back to YouTube all
the time, asking for all our users what’s
new, we just have to go and say, “Hey, what
happen on YouTube for the last five minutes?”
Maybe somebody there is one of our user, and
then we can grab his data. So we hope Google
is going to move forward on SUP, not only
for YouTube but across all its base, that’s
definitely one, one requirement. Two, I would
love an API on Google Reader. Right now it's
just more of like, just an RSS Feeds. I would
really like to be able to consume the Google
Reader Data, for example, with SUP, also having
the tagging, the commands, all included, so
this to be really an API. And number three,
you know, today was announcement of Wave,
so I just hope that it’s not a request,
it’s more a wish, I just hope that API is
going to be open enough, so that we can take
advantage of it but knowing Google, I know
my wish will be exhausted, so I’m looking
back – I’m looking forward to next year
to show you what we’ll be building with
Wave.
>> MALE: Awesome.
>> MALE: Thank you very much.